ont redonné vie à un quartier dévasté
par la guerre yarmouk banlieue
résidentielle non loin de damas qui
abritèrent en guerre de nombreux
réfugiés palestiniens retrouvent des
couleurs arraché en 2018 par les forces
gouvernementales aux djihadistes de
dèche la reconstruction piétine mais
depuis un mois les habitants de cette
ville sont autorisés par les autorités
syriennes à retourner chez eux
le 10 novembre le mini comité dirigé par
le gouverneur a décidé de commencer à
recevoir les demandes de retour des
résidents de yarmouth ces candidatures
ont déjà été soumises sous trois
conditions changent
la première condition concerne
l'intégrité structurelle du bien dans
lequel il souhaite retourner
la deuxième est de fournir une preuve de
propriété et la troisième condition et
d'obtenir les approbations requises des
autorités compétentes environ 50 à 60
formulaire de demande sont reçus
quotidiennement par nos services
parmi les immeubles partiellement ou
totalement effondré on aperçoit du linge
de maison et tendu signe d'une véritable
détermination chez les anciens résidants
de cette ville a retrouvé leur domicile
des habitants délogés par des années de
combats féroces yarmouk et tomber sous
la coupe des rebelles en 2012 basculons
trois ans plus tard aux mains des
jihadistes
à l'heure actuelle environ 40% des
bâtiments pourraient être réoccupée
quasiment immédiatement tandis que 40%
nécessite une réhabilitation
ce qui est loin d'effrayer les candidats
retour prêt à faire eux-mêmes les
travaux j'ai quitté ma maison ils
gagnent 9 ans j'ai fait des réparations
il y a vingt jours afin de pouvoir
rentrer chez moi j'habite actuellement
dans le quartier d'al galloise et je
suis prêt maintenant à vivre dans ma
maison de 80 mètres carrés où j'ai
grandi et dans laquelle je me sens plus
à l'aise que dans tous les palaces du
monde
près de 400 familles ont pu faire comme
mohamed
mais tous n'ont pas les moyens et les
capacités d'en faire autant quoi qu'il
en soit la vie reprend peu à peu ses
droits et certains commerces commencent
même à rouvrir
depuis une semaine à 10 jours je fais de
mon mieux pour exploiter le magasin avec
des capacités limitées afin de servir
les habitants de retour ici grâce à dieu
l'eau et l'électricité sont disponibles
pour le moment et nous espérons que tous
les résidents pourront retourner au camp
et que tous les problèmes seront résolus
les motifs d'espoir sont nombreux à
yarmouk mais le chemin est encore long
laissez rien tente de sortir la tête de
l'eau par tous les moyens dans un pays
morcelé par la guerre qui allait céder
fracture profonde en interne comme à
l'international